hello everyone and welcome to round
number two of the 2018 bill chest first
of all now in case you're just tuning in
these are the gentlemen that will be
entertaining us throughout this very
nice festival
and Google should really take note that
the bill chest festival is currently
being played and stop offering me images
of Jessica Biel but that is very
unlikely to happen so let us enjoy some
some nice photos from this festival here
we have a photo of course and and Maxime
from this round as you can see nothing
out of the ordinary in the photos but
you can see Carson is usual having his
water in next to his right leg and the
Maxime having a different beverage and
also an extra bottle stashed behind him
and also notice the position of the legs
Carson is wide open here and Maxime with
his legs completely completely closed he
seems to either be cold or or it's like
he's hiding something like like he just
made a terrible move and you know he
he's ashamed of it but regardless of
that we do have a nice photo for this is
this is a photo from the official feed
so it's not of the highest quality but
then again you know we best use what we
can as if you just google bill oh you're
just gonna get photos of Jessica Biel so
let's check it out Carlson has the black
pieces and Maxime opens with E for and
already on the first move across and
surprises him and goes for d6 the piers
opening or the first appears to defense
we have d4 Knight to f6 Knight to c3
we have g6 this is the main line and
already here
well there are a couple of very
interesting lines here Bishop to c4
Bishop to e3 f3 can be played Knight to
f3 can be played Maxime said that he
analyzed this position some time ago
from from blacks perspective and that he
saw that after Bishop to f4 a black can
have a very nice game and he thought
better up to f4 could take Magnus
Carlsen out of the book so Carson
continues we have c6 a normal developing
move characteristic for the Pierce
defense we have Knight to f3 but to g7
Queen to d2 the standard this
under setup the queen better battery
that white usually employs to play
Bishop to e6 and exchange the dark
square bishop and of course then simply
push push the G and the H pawn to
victory Bobby Fischer often said that he
he doesn't think the Pierce or the
Dragons Sicilian for that matter is a
good idea because well white simply
pushes g5 g4 h 4 and wins the game but
okay we have castles by cross on h3 and
now Queen to a5 now we have E 5 D
captors on e5 d captors on e5 Knight to
d5 and here Knight captors on d5 notice
that sometimes you can use this to your
advantage if for example white already
castled and played King to be 1 then
after this Knight captures on d5 move
and Queen captor Sundy - white would not
be in check and then white would have
this extra move of first capturing d7
pawn and then only then recapturing the
Queen which would win him a pawn but as
it isn't the case here in Bishop
captures on D - C capture son d5 and now
a queenside castle by maxing Raffaella
graph we have Knight to c6 Bishop to D
better up to c3 now opening up an attack
from the roof to the d5 pawn ecigs
defending h4 by Carlson and now h6 and
so far everything is perfectly fine for
white and black both Bishop to d3 to d7
simply developing rook HD one rook F to
c8 and rook to d2 preparing to double up
on the e-file locate the b8 and now rook
D to e 2 by Maxime Barcia holograph it's
not that he's you know trying to trying
to go all Aaron Eames of agent or or
really over protect this a five point he
wants to move this knife he wants to
play Knight to D for instance so far
only the bishop and the night were
defending d5 pawn when he plays Knight
to d4 no the bishop or the knight will
not be defending it so he needs two
rooks to defend the d5 pawn crossing
place b5 now we have night to d4 and now
before attacking the bishop on c3 Knight
captures on c6 we have Bishop captures
on c6 and now Bishop to d4 going for the
seven pawn Bishop to b5 first of course
now you can capture an a7 but you're not
really gonna get anything as rock to a8
is coming and then white is in trouble
so first King to d2 we have h5 now
f4 and Bishop to f8 g 4h captor son g4
and now comes rope to g1
brush up to c5 Bishop captures on c5
rook captures on c5 and rope captures on
g4 here the rook and King are aligned on
G file so h5 would definitely be a nice
move for white so first Carlson moves
the King King to f8 we have Luke to h2
by Maxine and now Bishop captures and on
d3 King captures on d3 and now maxime
thought that his position is excellent
that black has no counter play as he
said in an interview after the game h5
is definitely coming the rock is
infiltrating on the H file but here
across in plate rooked the c4 and the
maxime says that he missed this move and
now that his position definitely isn't
an easy one so Maxime continued with his
plan h5 g captures on h5 rook captures
on h5 and now King to e7 not allowing
rook to h8 of course to come with check
and now we have rook to look G to h4
it's not all that easy for white to come
up with a plan here a slightly better
idea perhaps would have been rook to h6
simply not allowing Carson Carson to
activate his rook by infiltrating via
the G or the H file so first going Rock
h6 and then going rook to f6 and then
you would hand black D H file but you
would get one extra move in your attempt
to attack the f7 point here Maxime
immediately went rook
G 2 H 4 and now rook to g8 comes
immediately we have f5 now rook to g3
check King to d2 and now Rock the g2
check King 31 and only now rook rook
from c4 captures on C 2 F 6 would check
we have kinked at King to e7
now comes route capture some before and
here we have a 5 first
rook to b8 and now comes Luke to F 2 so
here Carlson is already threatening rook
to f1 or rook to G 1 both of these moves
will be checkmate so you have to defend
this King to e1 rope to h1 was also
possible King to e1 who is somewhat
better and here you can't really pose
any any real threats with something like
rook to c2 white can what can simply
continue doing what he just did simply
go King to f1 or king to D 1 attack the
rope once again and then the rook will
have to go back so instead after King do
you want to first King to c6 across and
improves the position of a skink
rook the ch-check King to b5 and now
comes a rock to h7 the four by Carlsen
calls and starts pushing his past pawn
rook to g8
now if Coulson wants to trade rooks then
rook captures Maxine will capture an f2
cousin isn't interested look to e2 check
we have King to f1 and now rook to f1
check King to g1 and now comes Luke to
f4 rope to a for a very nice move
getting this rock out of f2 so the king
is no longer attacking gates now this
rock can move and it's free to either
capture on e5 or and B to rock captors
on f7 is played now rook captures and e5
is played and we have rocked a c7 rook
captures on f6 and rook to b8 so Crossin
is now up upon what his king is a very
very very active and it's okay to have
an active King but it's not okay to have
a too active King for example if you go
something like King a Ford and rook the
c-4 will result in checkmate
but okay after rook to b8 check King to
a6 now there is no immediate threat of
of pretty much anything Rock the c6
check King to a7 and now there are no
more checks the rock has to move
we have rocked the g8 and here you could
proceed in a lot of ways you could start
with rook to e1 check or or what not but
first across and plays rook to f7
not allowing rook to g7 to continue
checking Carlson's King we have roof to
g6 now with a double attack against the
e6 pawn and now comes Luke to e1
King to g2 and now d3 cousin again
pushes his passport rook to d6 you have
to put a row behind the past
one rook to e to check King to h3 and
now D to as the rook from e2 is now
guarding V to Luke the g8 we have King
to be seven and now rook G to d8 now
putting if putting one row behind the
past point is good obviously putting two
rooks behind a passed pawn must be
better here Carson as his d2 point is
now in the way of him capturing the b2
point he simply promotes it we have
captures cross and captures on Vito
again keeping up his extra pawn rook to
e1 now attacking cousins passed upon
rook to f6 defending it and now rook to
d6 again with a double attack against d6
pawn rook captures on a2 is played and
now kink the g3 of course you can win a
pawn here let's say D captures rook
captures rook captures but the white
king is too far away and the D a pawn
would would simply be winning so after
rook captures an a2 King the g3 is
played we have looked to be to making
room for the a point to be pushed rook
to e5 and now comes roof to b3 check
King moves to G to and from now a for
now cousin starts pushing his a pawn
we have rook to a five again maxime push
puts his rock behind the passed pawn a 3
as the b3 rook is protecting it and now
comes look D to a 6 again putting two
rooks behind a passed pawn rook f2 f3
and now you have to you have to do
something it's it's White's move so what
do you do here obviously you have two
options
you will either start checking the black
king or you will capture the e6 pawn so
let's see what happens if rook captures
on e6 is played well you get rook to c3
a very nice move because now after you
move the rook back if that's what you
want to do this doesn't work because you
get rugby to check King has to move and
now rook to c1 will simply be checkmate
so after this rook F to see to remove
you cannot move the rook back behind a
passed pawn you have to play something
like rook to e2 to avoid checkmate then
you get rogue back to c6 King to have to
enter now rook to a6 and it's all over
characters captures and now da pawn
simply wins the game whatever you play
rock to b2 is coming and then it's it's
simply too strong
s'okay a rook F 2 F 3 Maxime did not
capture the pawn he played her rook to
a7 check King to c6 was played now comes
rook 7 to 8 6 check King d7 rook to a7
check King d6 rook 7 to 8 6 check once
again and now King finally comes to e7
rope to e5 not with a double attack
against the exponent although Maxime
will not win this exponent would check
it gives cross and 1 move to improve his
position and cousin uses it excellently
rook F the c3 and this is a very
important move we have rook captures on
e6 King to d7 now and now you could
continue we're checking the King but you
have only one and then the king will
hide hide behind his c3 rook
so here King to have 2 is played rook to
b2 by Carlson
this comes with check rook to e2
blocking and by this point Peters
withers game with young Nico was already
over so then your King was interviewing
him and here they were discussing the
position and it was like oh yeah I mean
now Maxime really got you know improved
his position this is probably a draw and
it took him it took them some time to
really figure out that this in fact was
not a draw but you know if you're up up
to the challenge feel free to pause the
video here and try to find a winning
move for Carlson in this position so I
will give it a couple of seconds you
know give it as much as you'd like
because as you've just heard it took a
Peter Svidler and Daniel King awhile to
figure this out so there you have it for
those of you who were able able to do it
congratulations you are an amazing
amazing endgame player and for those of
you just want to enjoy it so if you
found Rock to be 3 then that is
perfectly fine simply improving the
position of the rooks controlling the a3
pawn and still controlling the spin and
then the king will be able to join the
action here and and and then go down the
board but the move calcine played in the
game is actually rook to h3 rope to h3 a
very nice move now again you have to do
something with white what do you do here
here the most natural and strongest move
is rook to King to g2 simply
the h3 rook but now this is the problem
we have rope captures any two with check
King captures on h3 and now a two so now
the past pawn is pushed to the second
rank and now now you'll see the problem
King to g3 is played King to c7 we have
King to f3 and now cousin gets this very
important crucial game-winning tempo
that is king to be seven now of course
white cannot capture the rook because
black captures on a6 and then the passed
pawn is winning so you have to move the
rook rook to e4 but now comes yet
another very important crucial move rook
to h2 the only move that wins the game
because now you will have another
another very important tempo now if you
move the King over here King g3 now you
get a rook to be two and now it will
take the White King one move longer than
the black King to improve the position
and able to be able to win this game so
after rook to h2 King to III was played
but now comes King to b6 now we have
King to d3 King 2b file was played now
attacking the rook as you can see the
black Kingdom made it to the critical
Square before the White King rook to e8
and now kink the before and after cousin
played King before magazine for Sheila
graph simply resigned the game there is
and there is nothing to do here whatever
you do you can either push the King to
d4 you can the second rank is not
available to the white white King if you
push the King then the King simply goes
down King to b3 and if you start
checking the King for example rope to be
eight which is the more obvious choice
you can simply hide King to a3 rookie
chair King bee to rook b8 check King c1
rook c8 check King b1 and now when the
Kings and be one after this check the
rook will block the check and now it's
all over as a one wins the game on the
next move so after this King to before a
brilliant game by Carlson and like he
said in the end game I like I said in
the interview after the game it's very
hard to pinpoint where exactly
maxime went wrong
in the interview after the game Maxime
said that Carlson could have won this
game much sooner and then he showed some
variations but the engine did not agree
with just the engine pretty much agreed
with everything across and played in the
critical positions so yeah two games
that he didn't really outplay his
opponents or or anything but there's two
wins after two runs for Magnus Carlsen
so definitely doing it again doing the
impossible and doing something he's very
well known for so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Benjamin Tovar and Michael Miller
for a contribution to my channel thank a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check through my previous videos
here I think y'all for watching and I
will see you soon
most likely with another game from this
festival from round number two a nice
Peter Svidler game and then we're gonna
check out the standings after round two
I think I'll and I'll see you soon